quello che vi racconto io comincia da
una casella postale Allora casella
postale elettronica io la rivista
scientifica un po' come Queste qui e
questa casella postale ogni mese riceve
centinaia di articoli sono centinaia di
articoli che sono scritti da scienziati
di tutto il mondo che vogliono che
questo articolo sia pubblicato perché
perché vogliono condividere i risultati
delle ricerche con con i colleghi e
anche perché poi attraverso gli articoli
si giudicherà il loro lavoro è un modo
per quantificare il loro lavoro
Ma chi è che alla fine poi decide cosa
debba essere pubblicato e cosa in
effetti poi si possa quindi Chiamare
Scienza Beh era come scientifica la
comunità scientifica come rappresentante
della società perché poi insomma la
scienza diciamocelo in fondo è di tutti
no cioè il progresso tecnologico il
progresso medico ma anche semplicemente
il progresso nel campo della conoscenza
la conoscenza del mondo dell'universo
sono tutte conquiste che partono dal
lavoro di scienziati che magari al
momento non immagino neanche dove
arriveranno le loro lavoro e lo rinforzi
e quindi ci vuole un metodo un metodo
che si chiama di revisione scientifica
attraverso il quale la comunità la
comunità scientifica possa possa
verificare la validità di questi di
questi risultati scientifici e possa
verificare la riproducibilità perché poi
alla fine sei un fenomeno viene
osservato una volta non è che sembra
molto insomma ecco adesso vi faccio un
esempio un conto esempio se volete si
parla spesso di medicina alternativa io
adesso non è che vengo qui a dirvi se è
efficace Oppure almeno non aspetta
sicuramente a me quello che però posso
dire è che nella maggior parte dei casi
non si può parlare di scienza perché
quei tipi di medicine alternative Non
sono andato Non sono passati attraverso
quel metodo di revisione scientifica
quindi la comunità scientifica che deve
decidere e quindi che c'entro io io non
faccio Ricerca Scientifica No però l'ho
fatto per un certo periodo Questo sono
io lo dico perché insomma capisco che ci
sono differenze di questi 16 anni fa
qualche capello grigio in meno qui è un
laboratorio dove passavo i miei giorni
le mie notti Sabri domenica e facevo
questo esperimento di ottica coi laser e
mi piaceva mi piaceva molto però a un
certo punto mi sono accorto che in
realtà mi piaceva molto di più leggere
gli articoli vedere gli articoli che
venivano dalla parte all'altra da un
gruppo e dall'altra e vedere come il
campo in cui lavoravo si evolveva
attraverso il lavoro degli altri
scienziati e gli articoli pubblicavano e
in particolare Mi sono cominciato a
Interessare al processo questo processo
di revisione scientifica attraverso il
quale si va dal laboratorio alla carta
stampata per modo di dire perché poi in
questi giorni naturalmente si parla
tutto di pubblicazione online
questo processo di revisione scientifica
è cambiato col tempo è cambiato negli
anni i primi esempi veri e propri si
hanno nel XVII secolo Quando nacquero le
prime società scientifiche per esempio
la Royal Society a Londra la versione
Nacque nel 1660 e proprio dal fondato da
alcuni pensatori intellettuali uomini di
scienza si dicevano anche si diceva
scienziati e questi questi pensatori Si
riunivano una volta a settimana e
osservavano un esperimenti in prima
persona poi ne discutevano
cercavano di capire se erano visibili o
no e via dicendo E pensate questa Questa
che vedete è una foto di una di una
finestra che si trova ancora adesso nel
nella grotta adesso questa è stata fatta
come commemorazione del trecentesimo
anniversario Ma si trova nella sede a
Londra e se vedessi Guardate bene ci si
vede ancora il motto che è nullius
inverta perché loro non si fidavano la
parola dovevano vedere dove osservare
magari discutere sentire dei periodi di
altri e via dicendo
Poi a un certo punto non non si poteva
più fare soltanto così perché Perché il
volume di di lavoro scientifico aumento
troppo e quindi nacquero le riviste
scientifiche e quindi gli scienziati
scrivevano gli articoli dove
raccontavano quello che avevano fatto e
quello che avevano osservato e davano
anche le istruzioni per ripetere queste
cose
e c'era un rettore che era uno
scienziato e che prendeva la decisione
lui magari sentendosi con alcuni
colleghi su su un articolo potesse può
essere pubblicato oppure no per esempio
se pensiamo all' Einstein molti dei
lavori di Einstein quelli più
fondamentali dall'effetto fotoelettrico
che poi gli valse il Nobel anche ai
primi articolo sulla relatività questi
furono tutti pubblicati così a un certo
punto però ha perso la metà del secolo
scorso Quindi negli anni 50 e il volume
era diventato così grande e soprattutto
la scienza era molto specializzata cioè
gli strumenti che venivano usati
bisognava essere esperti di quegli
strumenti per capire se erano stati
usati nella maniera giusta e quindi
venne introdotto all'inizio come
eccezione naturalmente ma poi diventò
poi la regola che usiamo ancora adesso e
se siamo tipi review
e su come funziona questo sistema lo
scienziato ancora scrive un articolo E
lo manda alla rivista il redattore
sceglie degli esperti e la manda a loro
di solito sono tre quattro cinque nei
casi estremi E questi esperti si leggono
l'articolo scrivono un rapporto scrivono
dei commenti dicendo Quali sono le cose
buone magari evidenziando anche i
problemi le cose che possono essere
migliorate le rimandano redattore
redattore di prendere l'elemento tutte
insieme prende una decisione la manda la
manda l'attore che così può modificare
l'articolo possibilmente migliorarlo e
poi possibilmente pubblicarlo
quindi si fa questo si fa Perché si
vuole migliorare la scienza si vuole
migliorare l'articolo e quindi
migliorare la scienza alla fine
Ma badate bene però questi esperti non
sono sono anonimi quindi l'autore
dell'articolo lo scienziato non sa chi
siano questi E perché questo perché
fondamentalmente Cioè se chiediamo a
chiunque Il motivo è che non
bisognerebbe evitare ritorsioni cioè
Supponiamo che che questi commenti siano
molto negativi è meglio non sapevi che
li ha fatti altrimenti ci potrebbero
essere situazioni in futuro a me però
piace pensare alla maniera leggermente
più positiva secondo me il modo per cui
il motivo per cui questi esperti che tra
l'altro in gergo si chiamano referì
quindi Arbitro o anche Pierce Che vuol
dire pari uguali non sono che ne so un
vincitore del premio Nobel o che
qualcuno che sta un università molto
famosa sono degli altri scienziati sono
degli uguali non ha importanza che si
crea quale sia la loro identità
questo si è molto bello No in un mondo
ideale
alle funzioni che abbiamo molto bene il
problema è che come ho detto prima lo
scienziato poi a seconda di Quanti
articoli pubblica E dove li pubblica poi
viene giudicato in realtà se chiediamo a
molti scienziati il modo in cui vedono
questo sistema è più di questo tipo cioè
pubblicare un articolo è un po' un po'
un Odisseo è un percorso ad ostacoli
ostacoli Viventi che sono questi questi
esperti che cercano in tutti i modi di
di non fargli pubblicare l'articolo la
verità che ci sono molti molte critiche
al sistema di Peer review Il primo è
quello di cui parlavo del fatto che
l'autore non sa chi sono i riferimenti
sanno che è l'autore
la seconda cosa che un sistema un po'
arcaico No cioè è tutto avviene per
email attraverso il web però ancora
avviene che l'autore manda l'articolo
alla rivista la rivista la manda gli
esperti gli esperti la rimandano insomma
si potrebbe fare qualcosa di meglio di
questi tempi e poi un po' aleatorio
anche no cioè solo due o tre esperti e
che succede se questi si sbagliano se
non capiscono gli errori o se magari
invece erroneamente pensano che ci siano
degli errori e poi infine ci sono i casi
di Frosini scientifiche Perché ci sono
anche queste vi fa vi do un esempio che
in fisica è molto molto famoso alcuni
anni fa quindici anni fa più o meno
a bella che è un posto dove uno dei
posti più importanti dove le
conquiste tecnologiche più importanti
c'è uno scienziato Che pubblicò decine e
decine di articoli con la b review su
elettronica molecolare devono gli
articoli bellissimo molto importanti Si
parlava di premio no bel in vista e
tutto quanto e poi si scoprì che si era
inventato tutto assolutamente tutto
quindi articolo gente che aveva lavorato
sulle stesse cose però va a ripetere le
cose non ci riusciva semplicemente
perché erano inventati
Va bene Allora ci sono molte critiche Ma
ci sono anche quelli che cercano di
trovare delle delle soluzioni Anziché
dire che fanno delle proposte e ci sono
degli esperimenti al momento sul sistema
di revisione scientifica che potremmo
chiamare eccezioni e che un giorno forse
potrebbe diventare in regola Adesso ve
ne racconto qualcuno alla prima è
abbastanza una piccola modifica Se
volete invece di rimangono anonimi ma
anche l'autore è anonimo cioè il
redattore nasconde nasconde l'identità
del dell'autore ai refill
ma in teoria non c'è niente di sbagliato
perché uno deve sapere che anche
dall'altro l'altro uno deve sapere
l'evidenza Che c'è Che non che abbiamo
adesso e che non fa tutta questa
differenza e l'altra cosa che sempre per
cercare di pensare in maniera positiva
Se una cosa del genere viene fatta una
modifica del Piano del genere viene
fatta viene fatta sulla base della
sfiducia cioè si pensa che c'è qualcuno
lì che ti vuole fregare a me questo non
piace Onestamente un altro tipo di
esperimento è uno che viene fatto una
rivista che si chiama High Life che
mette in contatto i refeiffel si
guardano l'articolo se lo leggono e
scrivono i loro commenti ma poi
redattore li mette in contatto e questi
di discutono magari si accorgono gli
errori e magari vengono viene fuori
qualcosa di nuovo Anche
ancora più innovativo è il sistema che
viene usato da una serie di
pubblicazioni che si chiama frontieres
che praticamente crea un forum che può
essere una cosa tipo Twitter o tipo
Facebook è un forum solo per gli autori
e pirere si possono scambiare le
opinioni per esempio preferivo avere
fatto questo questo controllo avete
fatto questo esperimento la torre
decisiva adesso lo faccio Torno fra un
mese dopo mese ritorna con una versione
o magari la Torre Felice Ma questa è una
cosa non c'entra nulla Non c'è bisogno e
via dicendo
Quindi è un sistema molto interattivo
molto collaborativo Ma poi chi dice che
ci devono essere riferiti
più di 2 3 o 4 preferite per esempio si
potrebbe mettere l'articolo online e
tutti commentano chi vuole commenta se
lo legge poi dice quello che pensa
la scelta di questo articolo non è
casuale questo è l'articolo sulla
struttura del DNA che non è stato non
hanno dato attraverso la pieve View
si sta molto Democratico No ognuno può
dire quello che pensa il problema è che
pensare e ci sono più o meno vengono
pubblicate centinaia di migliaia di
articoli ogni anno quindi come si fa a
scegliere quale articolo andarci a
leggere su quale commentare e poi alla
fine chi è che decide cosa che in
effetti è valido e cosa no
quindi si tratta veramente di democrazia
o si tratta più di anarchia è una cosa a
cui bisogna pensare secondo me molto
bene C'è un sistema che però funziona
Secondo me almeno ed è un sistema che
non è alternativo alla pubblicazione ma
è un sistema parallelo uno degli esempi
che vi faccio È un esempio che funziona
bene secondo me nella nel campo della
fisica teorica soprattutto ed è un
sistema attraverso il quale l'articolo
viene mandato alla rivista ma allo
stesso tempo viene anche condiviso con i
colleghi e quindi possono cominciare a
lavorare sulle basi di quei risultati e
la scienza continua a muoversi mentre si
aspetta che che
venga fuori
e adesso io dovrei dirvi che cosa
secondo me succederà Quale di queste
eccezioni diventerai una regola giusto
però io non lo so non ve lo so dire
penso che sia molto difficile saperlo
una cosa posso dirvi è l'augurio che mi
faccio io Io all'inizio ho detto l'ho
accennato brevemente ho detto che la
scienza è di tutti ed è una cosa
abbastanza ovvia No sono anche banale se
vogliamo un po' una i Cioè non è solo
degli scienziati di tutti quanti è
banale però se io ci credo davvero e
secondo me Quello deve essere il
principio fondamentale non Bisogna
pensare soltanto alla carriera di
Scienziati bisogna tenere questo
principe Certo ci sono degli effetti
collaterali che bisogna cercare Di
minimizzare Quindi io quello che mi
auguro che se c'è un modo diverso Ci
sarà un modo diverso nel futuro che
questo sia sia basato su questo
principio e quindi sia interattivo
collaborativo in cui veramente Gli
scienziati lavorano insieme per avanzare
la scienza e non soltanto le proprie
carriere Quindi adesso non so se sarà
esattamente il modello delle frontiere
che vi ho fatto vedere Ma secondo me
quello è un esperimento molto
interessante
ora una piccola previsione la faccio la
previsione è che secondo me il sistema
attuale non andrà via per un bel po' di
tempo perché in fondo non è non è così
male nel senso che funziona benino Sì
vabbè adesso potrebbero si potrebbe
cambiare questa cosa ed erano limitate
leggermente come vi ho detto secondo
quello che sappiamo al momento non ci
sono grosse differenze
e poi ci sono altre cose che si possono
fare
però fondamentalmente Questo funziona
abbastanza bene È vero che ci sono
soltanto 3/4 ore Feri Ma quando uno
scienziato poi pubblica 40-50 articoli
non è che tutte le volte può essere
sfortunato di trovare quelli che
vogliono ammazzare l'articolo o quello
che non capisce cosa l'articolo dice e
via dicendo Quindi alla lunga Secondo me
poi alla fine funziona e poi le frodi Sì
è vero ci sono le frodi che che non
vengono che non sono viste dal P review
però quello che noi non sappiamo è che
le frodi che vediamo sono quelle che
sono andate attraverso per review ma ce
ne sono moltissime altre che vengono
fermate La preview che non vengono
semplicemente alla luce del sole quindi
non vengono rese pubbliche
e quindi vi lascio con con una cosa che
si fa spesso nel campo delle librerie
scientifica ed è un paragone dal P
review e la democrazia e si usa spesso
una una frase di Churchill
sembra che cerchi l'abbia detto che la
democrazia non è perfetta Anzi
Probabilmente è il modo peggiore di
governare tranne tutti gli altri che
sono stati preparati fino adesso Quindi
non lo so La preview è la stessa cosa
forse non esattamente però insomma
Qualche similitudine secondo me c'è
Grazie